You think it's perfect.
Of course, not.
There are some problems.
One problem is, remember I told you
that the way you do the dot product,
since these are images, vectors, you can
just line them up and multiply them.
That was the dot product.
That's how you take the dot product of
these two 10,000-dimensional vectors.
That should have made you wonder,
well what happens if it's misaligned?
Right?
The eyes aren't exactly in
the right place.
Okay.
The scale is a little bit different.
The answer is,
it doesn't work very well.
All right.
It really requires good alignment
scaling.
Also the background has to be not too,
too terrible.
That can be done but it is a,
a sensitivity of method.
Another cute little story.
At the time they had
these 8,000 faces and
they wanted to put them in a scale,
in a, in a scaled lined up way.
And so, you could imagine trying to
write a computer program that would
sort of find where eyes were,
and then line them up, or
you could pay an undergraduate.
So, they paid an undergraduate
to click on the pupils of
the eyes of each picture
of the 8,000 pictures.
I think his first name was Wasi,
I cant remember.
If you're out there, my apologies.
And what was great as Sandy will tell
you is as a student who's working
on these 8,000 pictures,
he came back and said, I have a new,
new appreciation for
what order of magnitude means.
Because the difference
between doing 80 pictures and
8,000 pictures as you can
imagine took a long time.
But you basically you
have to line this up.
Now, You can use methods to
automatically align the eyes its scale,
et cetera, and
then that kind of thing will work.
Another limitation that is sort of
of a more theoretical basis for
PCA in general,
Principle Component Analysis.
Typically the way you do it is you take
your entire population, you find the,
the direction of variants
over the whole population.
You project down along
those dimensions and
then you try to discriminate
between the different classes.
In this data here, we have blue
points and we have red points.
But, if the first thing you did
was find the axis of elongation.
Okay.
The axis along which there
is the most variation.
All right.
And you projected these points down,
well clearly, you will confuse
the blue points and the red points.
All right.
So as it happens to be that
the way of separating the classes.
Right?
So the direction along which you want to
separate the classes is not
the direction along which the,
all the points are distributed.
There is methods in comp,
in pattern recognition Fisher Analysis,
Linear Discriminant Analysis, for
using not just the structure of
the population, but
the structure of the classes.
To determine which way to separate.
We won't talk about them here
because it's kind of an old method.
But it actually talks more about the
discriminative methods that we'll talk
about not next time, but the time after.
The idea is saying that,
well I don't need so much to model the,
the points themselves, because
the points are elongated this way
I need to model the separation
between the points.
So a limitation of PCA is that sometimes
the direction of maximum variance
is not always the best direction to
project on for doing classification.